FEMALE SPEAKER: Forest is going
to talk to us about
fakes and forgeries
in Southeast Asia.
So help me welcome
him to Google.
FORREST MCGILL: Hi, everybody.
Can you still hear all right
in the back and everything?
Good.
Thank you for coming.
It's fun for me to be
a Google today.
I've never been here before
and it's wonderful.
The problems of fakes in
Southeast Asian art are very
longstanding and complicated.
And one of the points of course
that comes up right
away is why would anybody be
bothering to fake Southeast
Asian artwork?
And it has to do with the
market, of course.
Southeast Asian artworks, great
ones, can bring hundreds
of thousands of dollars
or even more.
So if you're an artisan in
Southeast Asia, if you can
produce high-quality fakes and
sell them to dealers in
Zurich, and London, and New York
as the real thing, then
you'll make more money in one
month than you might make in
years otherwise.
The problem is very
longstanding.
I'm just showing you the names
of these two articles that
were published in 1943, already
talking about fakes.
So the problem is
not a new one.
Here in 1943, there's already
this recognition of the
problem of imitations,
fakes essentially.
And here's an illustration from
one of these articles in
1943 showing a series
of heads.
And according to the author,
this is the genuine one and
the other three in each
instance are fake.
And I think I could probably
have figured this out after
being in this field
for something like
going on 50 years now.
I think I could have
figured it out.
But the rest of the time today
is talking about how we get at
these issues.
This is at the Asian Art
Museum a few years ago.
We had an exhibition on fakes.
Museums used to get rid of their
fakes or put them in the
lowest level of the basement.
We get ours out pretty often
because we find that the
public is interested in them.
And we're interested
in them too.
And as you'll see in the course
of the talk today,
things that were thought to be
fake have sometimes come back
from the dead and turned out not
to be fake and vice versa.
And some things remain for
decades as uncertain.
We can't decide.
No amount of scholarship, no
amount of technical analysis
has decided the issue
in some instances.
If you had to vote in this
instance, how would you vote?
If I said one is for sure almost
a thousand years old
and the other one is made 30
years ago, how would you vote?
Right-hand side is the
fake, who votes for
the right-hand side?
You.
Left-hand side is the fake?
Well, maybe I won't tell you.
Maybe I'll make you come back
to the Asian Art Museum and
find out one of these days.
We have a good online database
with pictures and a lot of
information about
our artworks.
And you can access it through
our general website.
And these things and lots
of others are on there.
And the fakes are
on there too.
And they're registered
as a forgery usually.
Usually, it will say forgery of
the head of a Buddha image
or something like that.
So if you're interested,
you can find out.
And I think maybe I won't tell
you the answer in this
instance or at least
not right now.
Why did the market for
these fakes develop?
Well, it developed for the same
reason that the market
for Southeast Asian artworks
in general, especially
sculpture, developed at all.
And that was in part because
of the early world's fair.
Here's in 1889.
The world's fairs in Paris,
you know France was the
colonial power that
ruled Cambodia,
and Laos, and Vietnam.
Holland ruled Indonesia.
Britain ruled Burma.
So at the big worlds' fairs
and the big colonial
exposition, the colonial home
countries featured the
artworks of their colonies
to show their pride and
so on, and so on.
And in a whole succession of
worlds' fairs, there were
great Cambodian, ancient
Cambodian sculptures and other
works of art shown, and ones
from Indonesia, and ones from
Thailand, and ones from Burma.
And there was a lot of interest
from 1889 on.
There was a lot of interest in
Europe and eventually in
America too in Southeast
Asian art.
Well-to-do people wanted for
their library or their living
room the right kind of ancient
head or the right kind of
ancient sculpture to decorate
their homes with.
If you go to Southeast Asia
today, and maybe some of you
have been to these places,
this is Bali.
There are stone carving
workshops in Bali, in
Thailand, in Java, in other
parts of Southeast Asia that
are producing sculptures like
these for restaurants, for
gardens, for hotels.
And that means that the movement
of the stone, the
quarrying and the movement of
the stone is still very much a
going concern.
And the skills of carving
the stone are
very much still alive.
These are living traditions.
So if you're a stone worker, you
can get the stone and make
Buddha images or images of
Hindu deities or other
sculptures to sell to hotels,
or restaurants, or gardens,
people for their garden.
But if you're really good at it
and if you're unscrupulous,
you use the same skills, the
same materials, to make things
that eventually enter the
market as ancient
when they're not.
This is in Bangkok.
On the right-hand side
here is Bangkok.
And in Bangkok, if you go to the
right parts of town, there
are a lot of religious
paraphernalia
stores, just as--
well, I live in the Inner
Sunset in San Francisco.
And there's a store that sells
Russian Orthodox things,
things that are needed for
Russian Orthodox Church
services, and so on.
So you can go in and buy a
chalice, or the right kind of
crucifix, and so
on, and so on.
Well, there are religious
paraphernalia stores where you
can go and buy bronze and stone
Buddha images for the
temple back in your town.
And they're not fake.
They're made in the traditional
ways and they're
often made in the traditional
style.
But obviously, they're not
intended as forgeries.
They're just something that you
can go buy and take back
and donate to your
local temple.
And the factories for making
bronze images are still very
much there.
So exactly the same kinds of
techniques that have been
being used for over a thousand
years are still being used,
the same material.
And if you go to Thailand, or
Java, or Bali, or Burma for
that matter, Cambodia, you can
go and visit bronze casting
workshops like this and see
things being made today in
exactly the same techniques and
with the same materials
that they always have.
So I wanted to show you some
sculptures that from the
museum point of view are
clearly not old.
When we see these nowadays, we
can say this isn't a problem.
We don't need to think
about it anymore.
They're clearly not old.
And of course, it begs the
question of how do we know?
And sometimes it isn't a problem
to figure it out.
I have 20-something goddaughter
who's quite a
fashion maven.
And she can tell a real designer
handbag from a
knock-off handbag, a knock-off
copy of a designer handbag.
She can tell very readily.
She's looked at plenty of
handbags and she knows a real
one from a knock-off.
And there's lots in the area of
Southeast Asian are where
somebody who has been looking
at these things for decades
and seen lots of real ones and
studied lots of real ones, you
just get familiar enough.
I was thinking at lunch,
are there knock-offs of
Google Glass yet?
Can you buy cheap imitations?
Obviously if you can, then you
all, who know this stuff very
well, can tell the imitations
from the real thing easily.
So there are a lot of instances
where it's not so hard.
This one has a lot of stylistic
features that aren't right.
The color is strange
and so on.
Then here's one that also you
would say, if you've been in
the field for a while or looked
at a lot of these for a
while, you'd say right
off it must be fake.
And it's partly because we know
in this instance exactly
what it's copying.
The center and right-hand
pictures are probably the most
famous Buddha image
in Thailand.
And so this small one in the
Asian Art Museum collection,
this small forgery, is just a
copy of this one, which is
very large.
And the one that we have
in the Asian Art Museum
collection may not even have
started out life as a forgery.
It may have started out life
just as a copy, a modern copy
that you could go and buy in the
way that you might go to a
souvenir store and
buy a miniature
Statue of Liberty something.
So it may not have been
intended to deceive
originally.
But then it gets into the market
and dealers don't know
or collectors don't know.
And so something new
can turn into
"supposedly" something old.
Then this is a stone relief from
Cambodia in the museum's
collection.
And it was made 50 years
ago, or something
like that is my guess.
And again, here's what it's
clearly basing itself on.
This is a thousand year old
stone relief that's now in a
museum in Paris.
But if you look at the features
one by one, the
hairdo of this figure, the way
the club is held, and so on,
and so, it becomes clear that
this is based on this, or
something very close to it.
Another thing about this one
that clues us in that it's a
forgery, again if you know the
material a bit, there simply
were not temples that had small
reliefs like this in
such a nice little frame.
There aren't any.
These would have come out
of temples anyway.
There aren't any temples that
had sculptures of this type in
a nice little frame
of this size.
So it was made for the market.
And it was made in this--
well, this one is huge.
The one on your left was made in
this size and with the nice
little frame around it because
that's how someone would have
wanted it in their
living room.
So the artisans were responding
to what they take
to be the wishes
of the market.
Now, there's two technical tests
that we use all the time
at the museum-- and other
museums use them too--
for helping to determine what's
old and what's new.
Alloy composition testing,
that's straightforward.
Bronze is an alloy of
copper and tin.
And by analyzing it, you can
find out what the percentages
are and you can check whether
it's got the right kind of
alloy composition.
Thermoluminescence is a
technique that's just been
developed in the last
40 years or so.
And as best I understand it,
here's what happens.
When there's crystalline
minerals--
and clay is one, the clay that
we use for ceramics, and
bricks, and dishes, and so on.
When a crystalline mineral
like that is in the
atmosphere, it's absorbing
radiation from the atmosphere
and the surroundings.
When it's fired, so you take
this clay and make it into
something and you put it in the
kiln and fire it, all of
the energy that has been
absorbed, all the radiation
that's been absorbed,
is obliterated.
And so it's set back to 0.
And then it starts collecting
radiation, collecting energy
again from the moment
that it's fired.
So it's up at this level.
It goes down to 0.
And then it starts building
up again,
collecting this radiation.
So if you study the radiation
and test it against known
things, you can make a scale to
figure out, or to at least
estimate, how old a crystalline
material is.
And we use it for bronze images
like this all the time.
So in this instance, the alloy
is completely atypical.
And I'll show you
why in a minute.
And the TL test, the
thermoluminescence test, gives
a date of less than 100 years.
So we already thought it was
a fake on other grounds.
But the tests confirmed it.
Now I hope you're thinking to
yourself, why does a test that
works on crystalline minerals
like clay, what good does that
do us in looking at something
that's bronze?
Anybody know actually, what--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, aren't the
bronze castings fired in clay?
FORREST MCGILL: Well, yes.
Yes.
You're on the right track.
There fired in clay.
And they've got a clay
core inside.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
FORREST MCGILL: So to cast a
bronze like this, you make a
general model out of clay.
And then you put wax over
the whole thing.
And you model and carve all
the details in the wax.
Then you put clay over the whole
thing again and fire it.
And when you fire it,
of course the wax
melts and runs out.
So you're left with the space
where the wax used to be.
And where the wax used to be,
you pour molten bronze in.
That means that the core, that
original clay model that you
started out with,
is still inside.
And that's why we can use
thermoluminescence testing on
bronze because most Southeast
Asian bronzes still have the
original fired clay
core inside.
So we're not testing the bronze,
we're testing the core
that's inside it.
So for this image, here's
its alloy distribution.
And you can see it's got a whole
bunch of zinc in it,
which shouldn't be there.
This is a typical element
distribution in the alloy.
This is a typical one for
an ancient bronze.
So this big chunk of zinc and
the big chunk of lead suggest
to us that this is a modern
alloy, rather
than an ancient alloy.
Now, another category of things
that seemed suspicious
for one reason or another and
then get vindicated or further
study shows that there wasn't
a problem with them.
Here's a stone sculpture,
fragment of a stone sculpture
about this big.
Hiram Woodward is the great
specialist in Cambodian
sculpture in the Western
world these days.
He's the specialist who knows.
And he's studied all the
products of the most
provincial workshops way out
in rural Northwestern
Cambodia, and Northeastern
Thailand, and so on.
So if Woodward studies the piece
and says it looks like a
fake, but it isn't.
It's actually perfectly
all right.
We can take that, at least
tentatively, as the solution
to the problem for the time
being, pending further study.
I should say that for stone the
technical dating aspect is
much more challenging.
There's not tests that will tell
you when a piece of stone
was carved.
You can get the date of the
stone, you know 5 million
years or whatever.
But the date of the stone
doesn't tell you anything
about the date of when the
sculpture was made.
There are some analyses that
can be done on the surface.
Because if a piece of stone has
been buried for a thousand
years or it's been exposed to
the elements for a thousand
years, things happen on the
surface that you can detect by
taking little thin slivers of
a sample and looking at it
under the microscope.
But the fakers have found ways
to duplicate those effects.
In Southeast Asia, if you're a
clever faker, you carve things
out of stone and it is said
that you bury them
under the pig pen.
Apparently, this is a good
place to bury them.
You bury them under the pig pen
and leave them for your
children or your grandchildren
to dig up and sell.
After 40 years under the pig
pen, they've gotten the kind
of surface that they need to
fool people in the market.
Apparently, you can bake them
in various ways and fake
changes to the surface
by baking them.
And one of the things that
our conservation
scientists at the museum--
and conservation scientists
everywhere-- one of the things
they worry about is every time
they publish a paper, all the
fakers read it and figure out
a way to get around the new
testing methods that they've
come up with.
So it's very complicated
and challenging.
This is a little Cambodian
bronze.
In real life, it's about
six inches tall.
And it was acquired before
I came to the museum.
And when I first saw it, I
was very skeptical of it.
I thought that the style of the
female dancer and these
little tiny figures below the
central female dancer were--
I couldn't account for them.
And I'd never seen
anything like it.
And I searched, and searched,
and searched, trying to find a
piece of this size and this
orientation, with this kind of
frame around it, and so on.
And I absolutely couldn't
find one.
And I was very skeptical.
And we never put it on view
because I thought that it was
probably a fake.
But then we did an alloy
examination and the alloy
comes out fine.
This is what it should
look like.
And then eventually
I found a picture.
In a archaeological book
published in Thailand, I found
a picture of a quite similar
piece that came out of an
archaeological context.
So finding this picture with
a similar frame, a similar
dancing figure-- this one
is male of course
and this one is female.
But anyway, it made me feel
much more comfortable that
something like this could
have existed.
And we would show it
at the museum now.
I feel confident enough that
it's genuine and old, that we
would display
So finding the comparable
is very important too.
For some kinds of things, a
standard Buddha image, there
may be millions of
comparables, so--
millions is too many, but
hundreds of comparables.
But for an unusual piece like
this, just to find one
undoubtedly genuine comparable
is very helpful.
Then there's a whole category
of things for us where we've
never been able to--
well, where we've gotten the
questions involved care of.
This head of a Buddha image from
central Thailand, when I
first came to the museum and
saw it, I thought it was
almost too good to be true.
It's so beautiful.
It's in such good condition,
that I was very concerned.
But we did the tests on it.
We got typical alloy.
And the thermoluminescence test
gave the right kind of
dating range.
Notice though that the test
typically gives a span of 200
or 250 years.
If you're trying to figure out
whether something was made in
1500 or 1600, the test doesn't
do you any good.
It's not exact enough
for that.
But if the question is was it
made in 1950 or 1550, then the
test is plenty good enough
to be helpful.
This Buddha image came from the
collection of Doris Duke,
in her day one of the richest
people in the
world, in the 1950s.
Her family were among the
founders of Duke University.
Her ancestors had owned the
American Tobacco Company, a
very, very, very wealthy
heiress.
And Doris Duke collected
Southeast Asian art.
And eventually after her death,
a large part of her
collection was given to
the Asian Art Museum.
And I had picked out this object
from her collection to
take for the museum, thinking
that there was a pretty good
chance that it was genuine.
And that even if it wasn't,
since it was coming to us as a
gift, there was no reason
not to take it.
If there was any chance
that it was
genuine, was worth taking.
And we did the tests on it
and got good results.
And also just getting it into
the museum, and getting it
cleaned up, and getting
a chance to look at it
carefully, and getting new
photography made, it's amazing
how much better things look
after they've been put at the
right height on display, and
photographed beautifully, and
had good lighting.
It makes an enormous
difference.
Now, this is a glazed clay,
low-relief sculpture.
In real life, it's about almost
two feet tall and very
challenging.
There are a series of these that
are in museums and that
have been appearing in the
market over the last probably
generation and a half.
And they're very puzzling.
We have three.
I'll show you our three
in a minute.
And all three of ours have had
thermoluminescence tests and
they've all been inconclusive.
And some other museums have done
thermoluminescence tests
on their ones of these, this
exact same type, supposedly
from this exact place and this
exact period in Central Burma.
And the thermoluminescence
tests have often been
inconclusive.
And inconclusive means
It doesn't tell you anything.
It just means that for one
reason or another, the test
won't work.
And one of the problems--
this doesn't apply to Burma--
but for instance in Indonesia,
when you try to do
thermoluminescence tests on
Indonesian clay objects or
bronzes that have clay cores,
you often get no result at all
because of all the volcanic
activity and the
volcanic soil.
All the volcanic activity has
messed up the accumulation and
loss and reaccumulation
of radiation.
So for Indonesian things, often
you can't get a good
test result.
On grounds of style, and on
reading the inscription up at
the top and so on, this one has
always thought probably to
be genuine.
The temple that it came from,
the temple site that it came
from is still there in Burma.
It's fallen completely
into ruins.
It was brick and it collapsed
100 years ago.
Very little was left, except
piles of collapsed bricks and
some of these glazed
ceramic sculptures.
And they were removed by
whoever, 100 years ago.
And then made it into
museums in Burma.
Made it into the West for the
Western market, made it into
museums and so on.
Here's another one, supposedly
from exactly the same site,
also glazed ceramic.
And in this instance,
we retested.
And the second time we
did the test, we
got a credible result.
But we still don't feel
too secure about it.
If the first test was
inconclusive, and a second
test got a kind of result that
would make us happy, it still
leaves us uncertain.
Because if you test it the third
time, who knows what
result you would
get yet again.
And here's the third one
in our collection.
All of these are these wonderful
sort of whimsical
demons getting overcome
by the Buddha's power.
And this one had an inconclusive
TL test.
So what do we do?
Well, going back to the first
one, a scholar who lives in
the Bay Area, who's a specialist
in ancient Burmese
material, has spent a lot of
time at the site where these
were originally installed, the
temple in Central Burma where
they were originally
installed.
And he picked up at the
site this fragment.
And you can see that this
fragment is just like this.
It's a skirt, and legs,
and a foot.
So we brought this into our lab
and compared this side by
side with this, and this one
having come from the site.
And our conservation scientist
then felt quite confident in
saying that the materials of
this, the glazing of this, the
weathering of this is quite
uniform, quite consistent with
this piece that came from
the site itself.
And so we feel vindicated in
thinking that this one is
genuinely old.
Then of course you hit
the books again.
And one of the things that's
very important to
archaeologists and art
historians is old photographs.
So this is a book published in
1892 filled with photographs
taken before 1892 obviously.
And this is a bunch of these
glazed, fired clay panels with
demons and other figures
in them.
Here they are piled
up at the site.
And our two don't turn up.
But this one of ours
is clearly in the
same ballpark as these.
And this one of ours
is clearly in the
same ballpark as these.
So finding this photograph
again helped us to feel
confident that ours were
genuinely old and that they
came from this site.
Then there's a whole series of
problems about things that
live somewhere between old and
new or genuine and fake.
Here's an instance where a
perfectly good body has a new
head put on it.
And this is not uncommon
at all.
And it's a point of
pride for me--
I don't often get these and
I'm going to show you a
horrible mistake that I
made in a few minutes.
But it's a point of pride
for me that--
when I first saw this,
I said to myself, the
body's got to be OK.
The head's got to be new.
And when we did a lot of
testing, X-raying, the TL test
on both the body and the head,
this idea was confirmed, that
a new head has been made
and put on a body.
Because obviously, a body with
no head will bring much less
money on the market,
than a body with a
nice head like this.
We may pull the head off
one of these days and
just display the body.
But for now, we're keeping it
like this because it's an
interesting model for people to
look at of a part genuine,
part new object.
Here's another instance
where the head and the
body don't go together.
But they're both old.
So a genuine old head was put on
a genuine old body that it
didn't belong to.
Or this one, this is a glazed
ceramic elephant.
In real life, it's about--
again almost--
between a foot and
2 feet tall.
And when you see it like this,
it all looks fine.
And we very much hoped that
it would be fine.
I wanted it to be fine because
I wanted to use it in an
exhibition.
But when our conservation
scientist gave it a good look,
they found that it has
lots of repair.
So all of the areas on here
marked in red are repair.
So the figures by the legs, and
the figure on the back,
and the part of this little
stand that has the vase in it
on the elephant's back, all
made new and added.
And you certainly can't tell it
when you look at the thing.
And this is part
of the problem.
The ability of the restorer to
add missing pieces that looked
just right, and to dirty them
up, and antique them so that
you're not at all immediately
aware that there's very
substantial areas
of repair here.
They're very skillful at that.
Here's an X-ray of
the upper part.
And so you can see for instance
the join here, where
the lower part of this
body may be real.
The upper part is new.
The little vase on the back of
the elephant is genuine and
old, but it may not go
with this elephant.
Everything between it and the
elephant's back is new.
And so we don't know whether
that was just lost, but the
original little vase still was
there and was able to be put
back or whether a new
little vase--
not a new, an old, different
little vase was
added to this elephant.
Then we work on this
stuff all the time.
And we've got a number of
questions that we've never
been able to answer.
This metal Buddha image from
Burma was acquired by the
museum, again years ago,
before my time.
And if it's genuine and
old, it's a very rare
and important piece.
Here's a Buddha image in Burma
of undoubted authenticity,
undoubted age, that this
one is related to.
And it could be related because
they were both made in
the year 1200.
Or they could be related because
this one is simply a
copy or a forgery of a piece
rather like that.
One of the challenges with
this one is that it's a
strange alloy of copper,
zinc, and nickel.
But this alloy was used
in Southern China.
It may have been used in
Burma in the old days.
So even though it's a very
strange alloy, we
haven't been able to--
well, what we have found is that
this strange alloy does
occur sometimes in areas not
too far away from Burma.
So the strange alloy doesn't
in itself disprove the
authenticity of the piece.
Then this one is another
one from the Doris Duke
collection.
And it seemed to me clear that
the head and the body don't go
together in this instance.
We've now tested them both and
both the head and the body
seem to be new from the
thermoluminescence test.
But I'm still not convinced.
I still have a notion that
the body is old and
that the head is new.
And there's still a possibility
of how the test
results could be in this
instance confusing the issue.
Because if the head was
essentially welded on to an
old body, the heat from the
welding may have reset the
radiation accumulation
in the body.
So there are scenarios where
a repair to a genuinely old
object completely messes up the
thermoluminescence reading
and so you get a
false negative.
This one remained unresolved
though.
This is the back of it.
This is what a TL test
report looks like.
We send them to Oxford
in England.
That's the big lab.
And you get back this
thing saying, less
than 100 years ago.
Not consistent with the supposed
date of manufacture.
Now, a last example.
This painting, which is in real
life not much bigger than
a regular sheet of paper,
it's painted on cloth.
And it's really beautifully
painted.
And I was very excited when it
came to the museum as a gift
because there are plenty of big
paintings on cloth from
Thailand, from the
19th century.
But we've never found one
made before about 1800.
And they must have existed.
And in the tropical climate
of Thailand, things don't
survive very well.
But it seemed like that since
there are plenty from the 19th
century, there must be
some from earlier.
And I got in touch with Henry
Ginsberg, who at that time was
a curator at the British
Library in London.
He's a specialist in the
painting of Thailand.
He died a few years ago.
But this was when he was
still very active.
And he was also extremely
excited about this painting.
And we thought we had made
a real discovery.
This is a manuscript from
the 18th century.
And look at the picture.
I'm sorry, it's gotten
washed out.
Look at the picture in the
upper left-hand corner.
And you can see that it's very
similar to the one we were
just looking at.
Or this is the one from the
manuscript, the one above and
the one below.
So you can see how this painting
combines the figures
from the manuscript painting
above and the landscape with
the prancing deer from the
manuscript illustration that's
immediately below it.
And the inscription
also is related.
And Henry Ginsberg at that
British Library was a
specialist in ancient
Thai script and
ancient Thai language.
And he confirmed that the
inscriptions on this painting
were absolutely authentic for
the 18th century or perhaps
even a little earlier.
So we were very, very
excited about this.
Because we felt that we had
finally found a fragment of
the tradition of painting on
cloth that existed strongly in
the 19th century, that
no one had ever
found an example earlier.
And then to make it even more
exciting, we found a exactly
parallel painting in another
museum collection.
This is at LACMA, the Los
Angeles County Museum of Art
in Los Angeles.
And they have this painting, in
fact exactly the same size
as the one from the
Asian Art Museum.
I've just blow it up here.
But they're exactly
the same size.
They're both painted on cloth.
They both relate back to
that manuscript that
I was showing you.
That manuscript is at Harvard.
And both of these
relate to it.
So we felt that we must have
found a painting workshop in
the 18th century or perhaps even
earlier in Thailand that
produced both illustrated
manuscripts and big
paintings on cloth.
And our theory was that the two
paintings, the one above
my hand here, the one on the
right half of the screen and
the one from the Asian Art
Museum, were two fragments of
a much larger painting
like this.
These are two scenes, the Los
Angeles painting and our
painting, are two scenes
from the previous
lives of the Buddha.
And in Thailand, there are a
number of paintings, like this
one in the Asian Art Museum
collection, that show the last
10 lives of the Buddha, one
episode each, stacked up, two
over two, over two, making 10.
And so our theory was that the
painting in Los Angeles and
the painting at the Asian Art
Museum were both cut out of a
large painting like this.
And originally, there would
have been 10 scenes put
together in a very large
cloth painting, that
later got cut up.
Well, then we had an intern--
I understand that you've
got a lot of interns at
Google right now.
We had an intern--
don't ever get interns.
They'll mess up everything.
We had an intern who got
suspicious of this painting.
And she insisted on taking
a sample of the paint and
sending it off to a conservation
center and having
it analyzed.
And they sent back the results,
saying that the paint
included a pigment called
titanium white, which was
invented in 1924.
And therefore, the painting
could not have been painted
before 1924 because titanium
white didn't
exist before 1924.
We eventually sent the painting
itself to this lab.
And they wrote back and said
microscopic examination showed
that at some time during its
short history, the painting
has been pulled over the edge of
a board to induce cracking
and losses in order to suggest
greater age, thus making it a
forgery rather than a copy.
So it was intended to deceive.
Somebody had done that with it,
to make it crack and to
create some paint losses.
And so I wrote this to Henry
Ginsberg and said that I
didn't believe it.
And Henry Ginsberg wrote back.
Before he died, he was the
greatest specialist in Thai
painting in the world.
He wrote back and said, if the
banner, the painting that
we're imagining these two came
from or the Harvard manuscript
turn out to be forgeries, I
think I'll have to consider a
new career, possibly in
accounting or auto mechanics.
I hope it's not too
late to retrain.
So he was ready to, at least
in his joke, to abandon his
career for having been
mistaken about this.
What I didn't mention was the
Henry and I had published this
painting as the long lost
early painting.
We'd published it in a very
noticeable place.
And then it turned out that
we were completely wrong,
completely wrong.
We had been taken in by an
out-and-out forgery.
And so this is what we
eventually found out.
Henry Ginsberg tracked
this track this down.
A very good Thai painter
was at Harvard for a
period in the 1960s.
He saw the genuine manuscript
at Harvard and he made
forgeries based on the
manuscript at Harvard.
He needed some extra cash.
So he made some forgeries.
And we even know his name now.
He's dead too, unfortunately.
I wish he were still alive
so we could get
the rest of the story.
But it's an example of people
who have been immersed in the
field for decades, and decades,
and decades being
completely taken in, in part
because of their wish to--
I should say our wish
to discover
something that was lost.
But we were completely taken in
and learned a sad lesson.
And then of course, we had to
write to our colleagues at the
Los Angeles County Museum of
Art and say oh, by the way,
you know that great painting
that we told you about in your
collection that with so much
more valuable than you thought
it was, well, it turns
out it's a forgery.
So with that humiliation, I'll
stop and see if you have any
questions or comments?
AUDIENCE: Could we go back
to your [INAUDIBLE]?
FORREST MCGILL: Do you want to
know or do you want to guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FORREST MCGILL: OK.
Yeah.
Well, as best we can figure out,
this is the authentic one
and this the fake.
But it's not absolutely certain
on either side.
This could be a very,
very good fake.
And there's some outside
possibility
that this one is genuine.
It's facial features
are kind of funny.
This motif right there in the
middle of its crown is only
found on fakes that were made
in the 1920s and 1930s.
One of the reasons why the
Asian Art Museum wants to
publish its fakes is of course
any time any museum or any
collector finds a fake and
publishes it, then we can
compare against the fakes.
And enough of the confirmed
fakes of the 1920s, and '30s,
and early '40s, enough of them
have been seen or published
that we're able to recognize
certain features like this
funny little motif right there,
that seem to only turn
up in the fakes.
So that's very helpful.
AUDIENCE: With the
cross-example, does that take
on its own value as a result of
it's ability to appear as
if it's authentic and the fact
that a paper has published
about it and then you're able
to trace to the person?
So now it has its own value
as well, right?
FORREST MCGILL: Yes.
It's not the great historical
discovery that we hoped.
But the person who made
it was an artist.
So it's an interesting aspect of
his career, that he's been
shown to have had this little
sideline in making sort of
learned forgeries.
And it's quite wonderful
painting.
I mean I still like
it quite a lot.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then with the
bodies that are ancient and
the head put on that's
only 100 years
old, what is the value?
Is it still highly valuable
based on the body?
And is there like a--
not like a chart, or a price
chart, but how do you
delineate what the value of
all of these things are?
FORREST MCGILL: Well in that
instance, the value would be
the value of the body.
And the head is just an extra.
And if somebody bought it,
they'd decide whether to leave
the head on or not.
And they might put it in their
living room and keep the head
as a kind of conversation
piece, or to test their
friends, or whatever, or
they might take it off.
AUDIENCE: So you've been
referencing sort of-- you just
said like '20s, '30s
early '40s.
So basically this is when there
becomes awareness of the
notion that there's a
market for fakes.
And then has this died
out or increased?
FORREST MCGILL: Oh, the
market is flooded.
If you go to a dealer or if you
look at the big New York
and London auctions, in all
likelihood 50%, maybe 75%, is
very, very, very questionable.
AUDIENCE: And the techniques
get presumably better than
where they are?
FORREST MCGILL: Absolutely.
And as I mentioned, as
conservators find better
tests, then the fakers figure
out ways to simulate the right
test results.
So yeah, the fakes are getting
better and better.
And truly, I mean for a really
great piece of Cambodian stone
sculpture that would sell for
$2 million, it's worth a lot
of time and effort
for a faker to--
I mean even if they
spend two years
working on it, it would--
I mean to make a million
dollars in--
AUDIENCE: So do you just
not buy things?
I mean if you've got a three out
of four chance that what
you would potentially buy would
be fake, do you get to
these tasks before you buy?
I mean like how does a museum
create a collection?
FORREST MCGILL: Well, right, how
do we create a collection?
We don't much buy this kind of
material any more and neither
do other museums.
Because the issues of smuggling,
and looting, and
stealing from countries
in Asia is too great.
And the Asian Art Museum follows
the UNESCO treaty,
which is that we have to have
clear documentation that the
object was out of its country
of origin before 1970.
And that doesn't mean a letter
from your aunt in Switzerland
saying yes, I had this.
I mean there has to be a
really credible paper
trail to show that.
Collectors do buy things.
If they're smart, they insist
on very thorough analysis
ahead of time.
But as I hope you've seen,
sometimes no amount of
analysis can ultimately
answer the question.
So there's always a
degree of risk.
And that's true with-- you know
Jackson Pollock, a New
York artist of the 1940s,
apparently there are numbers
of fakes of Jackson Pollack's
out there now.
And certainly if you were going
out to buy a Rembrandt
or something, you'd have to be
very, very, very cautious
about fakes and about the
potential of getting an old
painting, a genuine old painting
that's had a lot of
repair or a lot of
over-painting, or a lot of doctoring.
So if you're a cautious
collector, you have to be very
aware of that and do your best
to check all that out before
you get into it.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious
for your perspective.
There's was an article recently
about a flurry of new
museums in China, many hundreds
in a very short
period of time.
And they singled out a
particular museum that had
recently seen a scandal
about the provenance.
Of the 40,000 exhibits, 40 were
deemed to be accurate
potentially, something
on that scale.
So if you're trying to build
museums or trying to educate
your population and share
cultural icons, how can you do
that in a scalable way in light
of the cost, and the
time, and the expertise that
has to be built over many,
many years?
What would be your system or
an ideal system short of a
UNESCO treaty approach?
FORREST MCGILL: Right.
One good thing is if there's
an archaeological dig and
interesting artifacts are
recovered, in some countries
they're all very thoroughly
photographed, very thoroughly
documented.
And then a hundred are sent off
to this provincial museum
and a hundred are sent off to
another provincial museum.
And that's good way to do
it because A, they're of
undoubted authenticity.
And B, they've all been recorded
and inventoried
before they're dispersed.
So you don't lose any of the
information about what was
together in the first place.
More and more, museums are
borrowing from each other.
And that's a good
way to do it.
We just recently had
a visitor from the
Portland, Oregon museum.
They want to have their first
gallery of Indian and
Southeast Asian art.
And we have a lot of very, very
good pieces that are in
our storage.
They're more than
we can display.
So they're asking
us to consider a
five-year renewable loan.
And we're inclined to do that.
So that's another thing.
I mean a lot of museums have
thousands or tens of thousands
of objects in storage.
And if they're good and if other
museums want them, then
let's get them out of the
basement and send them around.
AUDIENCE: So in the first
example that you showed with a
head and a body, you said that
you were very clear that the
head was fake and the
body was genuine.
When I looked at it, it did
not seem very clear to me.
So I was wondering what was
the instant tell for you?
FORREST MCGILL: Right,
well, one--
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]?
FORREST MCGILL: Sorry.
Sure.
One of the things that the
people in the field always
look at is necks.
Because heads have often gotten
broken off at some
point and reattached.
Even the real head gets broken
off and reattached.
So we're always looking
at necks.
You may not be able to
see it in this slide.
But if we had this object here
in the room, you'd be able to
see with your own eyes that
there's something funny at the
neck that suggests that either
a genuine head has been stuck
back on or some other head
has been struck back on.
So when you see that practically
glue mark--
I mean it isn't glue marks,
but you know what I mean.
You see something suspicious
at the neck,
it raises your suspicion.
And then they're a little
bit different color.
The corrosion on the surface of
the head and the body is a
little bit different.
Now, in itself doesn't
prove anything.
Because sometimes a head has
been broken off early on and
has been in different
conditions.
The body was more exposed to the
weather and the head was
buried deeper or something
like that.
So a difference in color or
corrosion wouldn't necessarily
prove that it's a problem.
But it's another little thing
to make you suspicious.
And then all the decoration on
the necklace here, it's like
little wire decoration.
And the crown has some
of that on it too,
but it's quite different.
And you would be able to see it
with your own eyes, if we
had the object here
to look at.
If I pointed it out to you and
I said, look at how different
the way these kind of wire
decorations are put on here
from how they are on here,
you'd be able to see it.
AUDIENCE: You touched on this
briefly during your
presentation, but I'm wondering
if you'd expound on
it a little bit more, the idea
of there are fakes and then
there are also replicas?
And so if you look at like a
Greek statuary, what we see in
museums is actually
Roman copies.
And your some museums will
display replicas right
alongside the genuine article.
So what is the role in museums
for displaying like the real
deal versus teaching
people about the
culture and the object?
FORREST MCGILL: Very,
very good question.
I mean we try to be careful
with our language.
So forgery means it's a copy
that was intended to deceive.
If we say "copy," that means
we're not sure that it was
intended to deceive.
The Roman copies of ancient
Greek statues, the ancient
Greek statues don't survive.
So the Roman copies are all
that we've got and they're
2,00 years old.
So everybody thinks they're
worth looking at anyway.
And for a lot of the stuff we've
been looking at today,
as far as we know there weren't
copies made until the
20th century.
So sometimes there were copies
made in the 20th century.
You know if you're a pious
Buddhist and you see a
photograph of a Buddha image
that strikes you as very
beautiful, you go to your local
workshop and say could
you make one that looks like
this because I want it for my
home shrine or I want it to be
able to donate to my temple?
So that's a possibility.
It's more complicated for
instance in China operation.
Where, as you may know, with
"old master" Chinese painting,
there's old, old, old
traditions of
both copying and forgery.
So a young artist would make
copies not intended to deceive
of older paintings as an
exercise, to learn the
technique and to master
the skill.
And those certainly are
shown in museums.
If it's artist B's copy of a
work by artist A, and even
artist B's copy is 500 years
old that's, very
interesting in itself.
The problem is that sometimes
artist B's copy, which might
have an inscription on it that
says I so and so made this
copy in 1520, somebody cuts off
the inscription and either
lets it go without an
inscription or adds a new
inscription, trying to make it,
after the fact, into an
original rather than a copy.
So things that started out life
as non-fooling copies, if
they fall into unscrupulous
hands, get repackaged as the
genuine article.
We try our best at the museum.
But if you had been really
watching what goes on in our
galleries over the last 10
years, you would have seen the
labels in some instances
going up and down.
And you would have seen things
disappear because we thought
they were genuine and then we
got serious doubts about them
and we took them off view.
And as I say, in our online
database we try do to stay
abreast of our latest research
and to tell the frank truth as
best we know it because we think
it's interesting and
useful to everybody.
Thanks a lot.